hey guys this is andrew from
tradingsenses.com i've been working as a
professional trailer for the past six
years in hong kong and right now i'm
doing
youtube videos because i want to pass
the knowledge guys i want to show you
how pro traders are actually working
and how we do our analysis so in today's
video i want to answer a very
interesting question guys
that i'm pretty sure you all have are we
in a bubble is the equity market
right now in a bubble and is it gonna
collapse soon
so to answer that question i'm gonna try
to use all the different tools that i
have
and actually give you my view and you're
gonna be pretty
shocked to see what i'm gonna tell you
let's get into it
[Music]
so first thing let's have a look on the
s p 500 i'm on a monthly time frame
basically this is just you know since
the 1929 crisis is just
going much higher but i'm on the
logarithmic scale yeah it's very
important when you look at long
price action and you just can't see the
first thing is that yes
you can feel that we're on a bubble
because look at the price action
took 75 percent in a matter of months
but i'm sorry guys if you just you know
look at this and compare to what we had
you know for the past hundred years
i don't see anything too crazy all right
so i'm gonna come back to this and i'm
gonna do a very
deep analysis and give you my answer to
tell you guys if yes or not we're in a
bubble
first i selected some articles that i
found interesting so i'm on
seeking alpha guys this is free you just
give your email address to this
website and you can access all the very
interesting articles what i can find
here i want to discuss a few stuff so
first in response to the figures
so the figures are the big equity
inflows that we saw
on the tenths of fab so bank of america
one that policy stimulus continues to
flow to wall street assets
not main street what does it mean guys
it means that all this money printing
that we are seeing for the past year
and actually it started in 208 guys very
quickly this is the fed balance sheet
so you can access this uh saint luis fed
its public data
and you can see the fed balance sheet is
how much money they actually created you
know fake money
and in 208 they started to print so they
printed 1 000
billion 2 000 billion and now in the uh
during the copied crisis they
they went from 4 000 billion to now
7.6 and it's still increasing so this
money is actually not going to the real
economy as it's supposed to
to do all right otherwise we would have
inflation the inflation is not
there yet they are actually fighting uh
to get
inflation around two percent but right
now it's around i think 1.5 on the
quarterly adjustment but it should be
much more
when we we see all the the money that we
print very quickly guys if you print
money
you increase the total amount of
currency
and the total amount of value that goes
against this currency is still the same
so for uh for example for one dollar you
should have
less value because now you have two
dollars for the same value so basically
this is called
inflation and we don't see it why
because this money
is going to the assets all right uh
equity bond market
so this is the first sign for me of
actually
something that is not healthy this is
creating more more inequality
you know inciting historic wealth
inequality
via asset bubbles so this is a sign of a
bubble i'm not saying
that we are in a bubble i mean actually
we are but
let me you know give you my answer step
by step but i don't think the bubble is
ready to burst
for sure but it's just creating you know
some
tensions so this wealth inequality that
is getting increased
when it's actually supposed to help the
real economy it's not
so this is not healthy for the market
and this is a sign of a bubble
then we have cathy woods who kathy wood
is actually the ceo
of arc investment management and
she's giving her view she's saying there
is no bubble on stocks
and she is very she's fully invested you
know in a lot of stocks
and she's saying that there is no bubble
but for her
we actually have another issue she's
seeing a bubble
in the bond market so she says if
anything
it's fixed income that is in a bubble
all right and squeeze rallies in
gamestop and amc that you guys saw i've
done a lot of videos
about it and you saw guys the insane
increase in the in the price action in
in just
a matter of few days so this is another
sign of a bubble
but she's saying that this is inflating
actually that bubble the fixed income
bubble
because it allows those companies to
raise more capital
without any change in the business model
that's true guys i did a video on amc
last week and i was showing you guys
what they did during the rally
they actually emitted more shots more
shots more shares
so they raised money through equity and
look
they raised money through equity but
still the bond market
so this is still kathy wood saying that
you know she's still here arc
invests good talking about what is
happening on amc
she's saying that we saw the bones
sending at five cents
before this uh crazy price uh increase
and then they have moved up to 80 cents
yes
times 16 and why have they done that
the move up in the stock gave amc the
opportunity to do an equity offering
that's what i just said they raised
money through equity but they're also
raising money through that they don't
need it you know
so this is a sign of a bubble why would
they actually sell bonds amc
when they actually can raise money
through equity with their stock going
higher so
the question is who will be left holding
the bag
if amc goes bankrupt all right people
who invest in the stocks
are going to lose money but people who
invest in the bones as well
so we need to be very careful and to
keep an eye on what is happening
here and another interesting thing that
i want to show you guys so here sam a
very interesting article i'm not going
to
go through all of this but basically
they are trying to tell you how bubbles
are working irrational exuberance and
the makings of a bubble
and what i think interesting here is
talking about bubble
they say they are runaway trains
unstoppable that misallocate capital
guys what we've seen we've seen that the
money that is supposed to go to the real
economy is going to the assets
the equity and the bond markets we've
seen that companies like amc
they can raise money for equity but
weirdly
and we don't understand why the bond
market is also increasing a lot
so it makes the rate going lower even if
the business model is not changed
so this is a capital misallocation a
nice example
and reshape the investment industry this
is
as well what is happening guys you know
the people who invest the money are
investing it
not based on fundamentals they just put
it in what is hot
as i've shown you guys in a lot of my
videos and as you
i mean you don't need me to to see that
you can feel it guys
and so many people starting to get
interested in the stock market
and they don't put the money where it
should i mean nobody knows where the
money should go
but definitely not in the companies that
lose money
and he concludes saying that talking
about this bubbles that the
end careers so this is you know some bad
stuff
that is happening when those bubbles
burst we
not having this yet for sure they
take some stopping so the thing is it's
very hard
to correctly identify a bubble situation
and extremely hard to time on
the realization usually comes after the
fact guys
this is where i actually come into the
game
and i'm gonna use my tools and i'm gonna
show you why
i think that we are not in a bubble yet
that the bubble is coming and i'm gonna
try to give you
some targets so this is now the
technical analysis
parts this is the s p 500 since 1929
so as you can see guys so i'm gonna on
the logarithmic scale
very important so as you can see guys
this market is just going higher
for those who have watched my previous
videos i like to use idiot wave
principle because it gives you
a lot of information about the market
because the market is actually
developing
waves each wave has a meaning for those
who are interested to know more about
that just click on the link
in the description of the video and
you're gonna receive a free video where
i explain
in details all these mechanisms and i'm
gonna show you some practical examples
but here i can also give you some nice
practical examples
i'm gonna try to identify the five waves
up so one two three four five
two and four are corrective so here
where do you see corrections
so this is one cycle for sure after the
1929
crisis we have one big cycle that is
going to develop in five waves as it
usually
does so we try first to identify
correction
faces here we have one okay definitely
so one
two this is a two because here it's
corrective and here is corrected so
basically this is a two this is a four
so this is giving me already this
so one two three
four and we are in a five so just very
quickly the five
i will put it here somewhere you know
you can put it here but then the five
looks short compared to one and three
right the five might go
maybe here so we are here on the s p 500
so just visually
it can go to 7 000 within like a few
years
it wouldn't be something crazy compared
to what we've seen in the past century
then now that we have that i'm gonna go
back on the weekly time frame
and i'm gonna try to analyze my fifth
wave and same thing guys i'm gonna try
to find
five waves in this one so let's start
we try first to find the corrective
patterns
so the question that everybody had was
was this a five
all right so we could do something like
this one
two three four five and everybody was
saying
you can see like you know a lot of
videos about that
everybody was saying here that yeah we
just uh
actually completed the fifth of the
fifth and that we're gonna have now the
massive correction of this
whole move up but the problem is that
if this was the case we should not
actually go
above here we should not have this rally
making new all-time highs and
you know just going crazy at this area
so when this happened
i knew guys that the thing were actually
different
here i was neutral i was bearish here
actually i was from those that thought
this would be the start
of something really bad but the fed
stepped in the game
and what they did was actually very
efficient and here i was
thinking that same thing the market is
going to revert and that this whole
pattern is actually
transformed into a new bearish pattern
but what happened is
very different and when actually
this you know happened here so basically
i
identified that here we had an expanding
triangle so this is what i i drew here
and what is actually happening guys
right now
is that we broke it on the upside and we
retested it once
twice and we go higher so from then on
i knew that this is a four you know
triangles usually are in the false wave
of idiot wave principle
and after i knew this was a four i knew
that the five is coming and i
i know that this counting here is not
correct so now i know that things are
like this guys
bam all right
so once again i don't know where the
fifth is going
i don't know yet but what i'm very
convinced
right now is that this is gonna act
as support the whole way up and it's
gonna
act as support for a few years so this
is giving me a nice
uh exit level if actually you know we
break it and this support is actually
going higher guys
so it gives you a very nice exit level
that is
increasing and we don't know how
far this can go but definitely guys we
have not completed
this market cycle so i'm gonna keep an
eye on this
and i'm gonna try to give you some
targets uh based
on what is happening for now the only
thing we can do is use
fib extensions so as usual i use field
extensions and measure the third wave
and i apply the move to my false wave
and the most common levels that usually
we are seeing in this kind of
development
is actually uh the 1.618 glue the number
and the 2.618
so this is giving me three hundred or
seven thousand
two hundred but guys i want to remind
you something
is that the situation is not actually
normal
we i think are in the bubble so if we
are in a bubble
it's not only gonna go to the 1.618 it's
probably going to go to
2.618 and this is giving me my target
for the fifth of the fifth
so i think we are going to 7200 in terms
of timing i'm not sure
i would say you know this can this can
be like this if it's a bubble
so maybe you know 2 or 23
something like this 2 or 24 i don't know
so you know
one two maximum three years i see the s
p
going to 7 7000 guys so take maybe
another
80 something like this all right guys so
that's it for me for now
i just did an analysis on the s p 500
and tried uh to show you
where we are in terms of development of
the waves i'm not done
with the analysis of the bubbles next
one i'm gonna do the nasdaq
and i'm gonna show you guys actually uh
what
indicators you can use to see if you are
in a bubble or not
so if you wanna know about this next
analysis don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys